[Music]
workload identity allows workloads in
your google kubernetes engine or gke
clusters to impersonate identity and
access management or iam service
accounts so that they can access google
cloud services without workload identity
enabled your workloads will use your gke
node's default service account
in this video we'll show you how to
enable workload identity on your gke
cluster and configure your apps to use
it you can enable workload identity
using the cloud console the google cloud
cli or the rest api
we'll first use the cloud console to
enable workload identity on an existing
cluster and then we'll use the cli to
configure an app to use workload
identity let's get started
go to the kubernetes engine page
select your cluster
scroll down to the security section
and under this section click the edit
icon next to workload identity
click the box to enable workload
identity then save your changes after a
few minutes your cluster is enabled with
workload identity
congratulations you now have a workload
identity enabled cluster
the node pool that we used already had a
test pod running let's see which service
account it uses
first we'll connect to the cluster
great we're in
let's exec into the test pod
then run the following command gcloud
auth list to find out which google
service account is used
it shows our node's default service
account
let's configure our pod to use workload
identity instead
now we'll use the google cloud cli to
tell an existing node pool to use
workload identity
we'll exit our test pod then update the
node pool to use the gke metadata server
this will take a few minutes you can
also create a new node pool
when your cluster has workload identity
enabled any new node pools will too
next create an iem service account for
our pod to impersonate
now we need to bind the kubernetes
service account that our pod uses to the
iem service account that we created
allow the kubernetes service account to
impersonate the google service account
by adding an iam policy binding between
the two service accounts
in our case we're using the default
kubernetes service account in the
default namespace
next annotate the kubernetes service
account so that workload identity knows
which google service account to use
workload identity is now configured with
the specified google service account
great we have successfully enabled and
configured workload identity on our gke
cluster time to test it out
remember the test pod was using the
default node service account earlier
let's see which service account is being
used now
let's exec back into the test pod
and run gcloud off list
it now shows the google service account
we just created and configured that's
because we bound our default kubernetes
service account to the iam service
account
so the pod was able to impersonate the
iem service account
congratulations you now have a workload
identity enabled gke cluster configured
to use an iem service account with your
workload read more about workload
identity in the documentation
[Music]
you